see youtubers it's Charlie we got to
talk about how James Gunn just
completely bound the biggest theory in
the Marvel Universe so I'll explain
what's going on but because these are
post credits just careful for spoilers
if you haven't seen the movie yet they
even had one of the biggest things on
par with Nick Fury showing up to tell
Tony Stark about the Avengers at the end
of the first Iron Man movie and there is
a ticket giveaway going on right now so
even if you've already seen it be sure
to go see it again it's one of those
movies is really good for repeat viewing
especially catching stuff that you
missed the first time all you have to do
to enter is be subscriber leave a
comment on this video so starting with
the first post credit scene crag land
has an accident playing with yondu's fin
in the air oh it was a great comedy I
loved Sean Gunn in the film I don't
think this means that he's going to be
the new yondu but I do think that he
will be in guardians of the galaxy 3
playing with the fin they might bring
that joke back the next post-credit
scene is probably one of the biggest on
par with the Adam warlock one so it's
the original guardians of the galaxy so
we obviously know that sylvester
stallone was playing star hawk now he's
the one that teases the idea that there
are a hundred different Ravager factions
that all have their different goals but
there's a code that they live by and
that's why yondu was exiled so what
they're teasing here is that there was
the original guardians of the galaxy
team from the comics which were called
the guardians 3000 that existed a long
time ago because you have to assume that
star hawk is in his late 50s early 60s
they had all kinds of crazy adventures
then yondu like he narrates during the
movie was an [ __ ] was selfish and
made the deal with Peter Quill's father
ego the Living Planet started
trafficking in children then he was
exiled in formed his own band of
Ravagers that were sort of on the outs
from the larger community so if you were
confused about the argument that they
had on the Ravager planet we'll call it
the Howard the Duck planet just because
that was a great easter egg to then that
was what was happening with their
dialogue he was teasing the explanation
for their history why he hated yondu so
much why he was an outsider it was sort
of meant to create the framework to give
you an understanding of what's happened
in the past as a galaxy like there's all
these stories that have happened we've
only met the new guardians shame
that is such a tragedy of losing yondu
to bring us all together again but I
think he'd be proud knowing that we're
back to the team was a resilient shoe so
at the end of the movie after they find
out that yondu sacrificed himself to
save Peter quill they have that big
ravager funeral they reunite because you
see them in the different ships so the
original guardians team is Sylvester
Stallone as Starhawk Ving Rhames
is Charlie 27 Michelle Yeoh is Aleta or
Gord star Hawks wife Kruger Michael
Rosenbaum as Martin X so that was who he
was playing if you're wondering and then
Miley Cyrus is mainframe if you couldn't
tell she was the voice of that robot
head he's more of an AI consciousness
than an actual robot but he narrates
that it's wonderful that they're all
together again it's sad that the death
of our friend is what it took for us to
come back together because it implies
they had this big breakup and they all
went their separate ways a long time ago
but then he suggests that they get back
together and how about we go steal some
[ __ ] so a lot of people were wondering
what does this mean because James Gunn
said that that team would actually pop
back up in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
not necessarily in guardians 3 so they
might pop up in the next infinity war
movie just somewhere in the cosmic
universe because James Gunn is planning
the next 10 years of Marvel cosmic films
so we're going to see a whole bunch more
Marvel movies set in outer space and
they could pop up in any of those movies
but when he was saying let's go steal
some [ __ ] he was just making an
offhanded remark let's go steal some
[ __ ] it was intended to be more of a
joke it's not they're going to go steal
an infinity stone or something like that
but the next big one obviously an
earth-shattering post-credits scene if
there ever was one the creation of Adam
warlock
so we Asian the sovereign as of the end
of guardians to are now at the top of
the list of guardians enemies next to
Thanos so Thanos sovereign then the Kree
the Kree still hate the crap out of them
there's bounties on all their heads so
all she really says is that she's
creating Adam warlock in a brand new
type of cocoon so he's going to be more
beautiful more powerful more terrible
and more capable of destroying the
guardians of the galaxy or
originally when he was created in the
comics it was by a group of humans on
earth called The Enclave he was intended
to be the space Jesus and then became
more of a cosmic character is sort of
like an opposite to Thanos so danis was
always the villain Adam warlock became
the force to balance that out eventually
they fought and he learned about the
soul gems and Adam warlock took
possession of them from Thanos and he
got trapped inside the soul gem but then
was rescued by the Silver Surfer then
during the infinity war arc he basically
became the lead person of all Earth's
heroes trying to stop Thanos from
destroying the universe so he's a huge
cosmic character they're already in the
middle of shooting the first infinity
war film so he's going to make it into
any of those fanno stories it's going to
have to be the fourth Avengers film
which doesn't shoot till later this year
they could totally do that if they want
but it sounds like he's going to be a
guardians of the galaxy three main
character and he'll start out as an
antagonist
but even though they changed a lot of
things about comic book backstories he
probably won't have an infinity stone
but by the end of this story he will be
on better terms with the Guardians
because he's sort of like a neutral
figure he can be really bad and he can
be really good he has the split part of
his personality that becomes the mages
that becomes a big thing I'm not
expecting them to do that in the name of
simplicity I'm just expecting him to
come out of that cocoon listen to the
sovereign explain why they hate the
Guardian so much so he thinks they're
villains goes after them but then
through the course of their adventures
learns that they're not so bad and it
sort of frees himself from the will of
the sovereign and becomes his own person
because it's a race it's implied that
they have a very strict caste structure
their roles in their society are very
predefined each person is created to
serve a specific function in a very
perfect organism that serves as their
society so it's almost like free will
doesn't exist but there were a lot of
funny moments during the movie like when
that sovereign was laughing a tazer
phases name that was a big runner joke
in the movie why did you name yourself
taser face that's the dumbest name ever
but Adam warlock is now part of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe they can do
whatever they want to with them but just
expecting to show up during guardians 3
the next big one is teenaged group thank
God that they're not going to do baby
group forever I loved him in the movie
he totally worked
but baby Groot is one of those really
cute things to could get old really
bath so now that he's teenage Groot it's
a lot easier to tell that Vin Diesel is
still doing the voice he did the voice
for baby Groot but they just processed
it differently after he read all those
lines but guardians 2 takes place two
months after guardians one the next time
we see the guardians during infinity war
will be four years after that
so presumably Groot will be full grown
and the other thing they teased in this
is that just like Han Solo Chewbacca
Peter quill can now understand
everything that Groot is saying then the
last big one to Stan Lee cameo that
unifies all Stan Lee cameos so there was
a theory a long time ago that people
came up with hey wouldn't it be cool if
Stan Lee were the same character in all
these Marvel cameos that he does but
what's happening here is that the
credits for the movie referred to him as
the agent of the Watchers so he's not a
watcher himself he just works for them
and goes down on earth and observes all
these big events and then communicates
them back to the watchers so if you
include this movie Stan Lee has had
thirty three separate cameos in Marvel
movies now that includes all the Fox
stuff that includes some TV stuff too
like agents of shield and you have to
remember that there's spider-man
homecoming he's going to have a cameo in
that their store another cameo and then
Bryan Singer confirmed that the x-men TV
series he's working on will have a Stan
Lee cameo as well so the list is growing
then you have all the Marvel stuff next
year like infinity war there's going to
be crazy Stan Lee cameos I think he can
get that number up to 50 he still seems
pretty healthy even though he's doing
less and less public events but the very
first cameo that he ever did in any
Marvel movie was during x-men in 2000 he
was a hot dog vendor so what I might do
later this year is just a montage of
every single Stan Lee cameo that
probably a pretty long video but let me
know in the comments what was your
favorite post-credits scene there were a
lot of other things that happen during
the post credits that are Easter eggs
that I'll talk about when I post that
video so that'll be later this weekend
just to give people more of a chance to
go see the movie so hopefully that
explains everything that happened most
of people's questions were just about
that Sylvester Stallone cameo the
original guardians team and what their
role is going to be in the future and
then all the Adam warlock stuffs just
because he's such a big character in the
stories that Marvel is getting ready to
do next year with the infinity war big
stuff though later this weekend there's
going to be a new Spider
homecoming trailer that's not going to
post til Sunday but just heads-up that
I'll do a video for that there'll be a
lot of spider-man you leave all your
requests for Marvel videos in the
comments below but if you're wondering
about the thor ragnarok connection
because yes the grandmaster does show up
dancing in the post-credits scenes
that's the only real connection to thor
ragnarok but there's a lot of stuff that
shows up in those credit sequences that
are easter eggs that I'll talk about
when I post that Easter Egg video but
congratulations to Peter Parker you're
the latest giveaway winner please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details there was a new round in this
video I'll just announce the winner the
next time I post a Marvel video while
you wait for that you can click here to
re-watch the defenders trailer and you
can click here for the new Marvel
Inhumans trailer thank you so much for
watching plus not five I'll see you guys
tonight